Il y a des jours oú tu n'as pas envie de jouer seul(e), devant ton computer
*rires*
J'ai cru que c'était Yannou qui était en train de parler. Attends j'entend j'entend parler moi dans le casque
qu'est ce qui se passe là ?
Pourquoi vous vous moquez ?
Devant mon micro ordinateur
*rires*
Ils ont tous gâchés
j'allais faire une intro cool, ils ont tout baisés!!
Aujourd'hui on est avec Cyril,Yann et Micka.
Bonjour!
et on va jouer au UNO!!!!
ce jeu auquel vous avez tous joué
en colonie de vacances quand vous étiez bien bien puceau jusqu'au sang
eh bien on ressaute dessus aujourd'hui et franchement c'est mon jeu d'société préferer
eh je sais pas si t'a remarquer mais il est vraiment bien ce jeu
euuuuuuh ouais
les amis préparer a des games décéptions
j'ai mit l'option accumulation parce que j'trouve ca très drôle
c'est que si tu te prend un +2 mais que tu es un +2 eh ben ca fait +4 pour le le mec qui joue après toi
c'est l'option hyper drôle on est d'accord
non mais moi je suis mort de rire là. bah voila
en vrai j'vais pas vous mentir les amis on sort d'une game qui a duré 20 minutes
*rires*
interminable parce qu'on a mit l'option ou quand tu peux pas jouer tu pioches
des cartes jusqu'a que t'en pioche une que tu peux jouer
voilà
eh la si mon public ne connait pas le uno les gars chui foutu
ehhhhh ils vont se faire chier.......
allez les gars que la game commence
que le meilleur gagne
euh n'eshiter pas a voter dans les commentaires comme ça ça me ferra du bon référencement pour la video
on y va. OK les gars
c'est partit on peut intèrcépter ? On peut intèrcépter .....
si t'as exactement la meme carte tu peut la poser meme si c'est pas ton tour
ooooh j'ai vraiment un jeu de merde
allez Yann ça dégage Yann ça dégage
ooh nonnnnn excellent
Cyril: euuh Micka est ce que tu aime les cartes
Micka: ouais
Cyril: tant mieux
*rire* mets toi bien Micka
hop laa!! ....... et je m'dirige je m'dirige en plein vers la victoire
ok Micka à toi tu commences un peu  à t'envoler
oooh putain
le batard j'y croyais
oh pl'a mais arrête aussi
c'est bon ça
si j'passe cette game ça serra plus rapide que la... ooh putain mais arrêter
tient Yann nannn
ooh putain au pl'a ! oooooooooh
ooh c'est incroyable s'qui ce passe c'est exceptionnel
c'est pas fou du coup j'vais p'têtre les données a Lucas Nannnnnnnnnnnnn
Contre-Uno les gars Contre-Uno cliquer cliquer j'sais pas ou c'est
*rire*
allez un peu de bleu
heinnn merci Yann
ça me fait très plaisir
tient Micka j'aimerai que tu pioche s'il te plaît
il bluf il bluf et je bluf ou pas
il bluf vasy tu bluf eh bah nann
et boum 6 cartes dans ta gueule
*rire* eh ça tryhard, y'a plus d'amitié
c'est fini. aah putain
et c'est pas grave parce que j'la vole
*rire* excellent *rire*
il a toutes les cartes l'enculer
merci beaucoup Lucas ah j'apprecie de rien
Cyril y'a des complots nazi dans l'équipe on est bien
Cyril attention c'est sérré c'est très sérré
ormit pour Micka qui va faire piocher Cyril dans pas longtemps
eh les gars contre-uno contre-uno pour Yann contre-uno pour Yann. Nonn CONTRE UNO !
*rire* attends attends qu'il joue
Putainnnnn
oooh il a pas de vert le con
*rire* contre uno sur Cyril préparez-vous
enfaite quand y'a uno contre uno il faut cliquer
préparez-vous j'sais pas ou faut cliquer mais on va cliquer les gars
bahhhh
Oh oui !
Oh nan Oh oui
Cyril je t'aime, tiens vas y
fais ton Uno, fais ton Uno.
NOOoooOOONNNnnnNNnn !
Ah bah non en fait.
*rires*
Oh nan
Attends attends attends, c'est pas fini !
*soupire*
Alors qu'est-ce qu'on va pouvoir mettre ?
Alors qu'est-ce que vous avez monsieur.......Du vert (x7)
ET BIIIIIIIM ET BIIIIIM
Oh nonnn !
Mais j'ai plein de cartes mais je peux pas...   Attention là ça va faire mal.
NAAAAAAAAAAN Excellent !
Il a pioché un +2 jaunes, l'enc*lé !
CONTRE UNO CONTRE UNO
Oh OH OH *RIRES* YES YES.
NON ! Mais non mais j'avais appuyé...
Mais c'est pas grave, t'as le droit d'être mauvais y'a pas de... pas de honte. *en chantant* N'aie pas le seumm,
Mais non !
Ta gu*ule !
*toujours en chantant* n'aie pas le seuuuummmeuh !
Micka est-ce que t'as un +2 ?
Non j'en ai pas...
N'ai pas le....Menteur ! c'est sa voix de menteur put*in j'vais me prendre un +2 !
Non mais si justement, si tu l'as tu peux bam !
Ben non j'en ai pas...
*Rires*
Bon ben on a perdu.
OOOOOOOH OUI !!!
On a perdu, eh ouais...P****n !
Non !
Le plus grand joueur d'UNO de France a gagné !!! WOOOOOOW !!!
Moi c'est ta vidéo, je te laisse gagner j'veux dire. Normal. (Mauvais perdant)
Ok tu sais quoi, on refera la revanche sur ta chaîne, (super konar)
on verra si tu vas gagner.
Les mecs se lancent des 1v1 au UNO quoi.
*Rires*
On va régler ça sur UNO
Ok c'est reparti !
Ok, un 4 vert.
À toi Micka.
Ah pu*ain..
bon ben tu joues pas.
Eh bin c'est pas... oh ba*ard !
Pu*ain
J'allais m'enflammer.
Cyril Cyril on va s'allier on va s'allier, on va les défoncer.
Tu veux quoi comme couleur dis-moi ?
Vas-y vas-y bleu ou vert ça m'arrange.
*rire de Mickalow*
Bah pas de soucis.
*rire*
Genre le mec il a ce qu'il faut ! Allez Yan tu fermes ton c*l
Allez s'te plaît Cyril.
*rires*
Allez !
Continue comme ça Cyril, continue comme ça.
Nan Cyril fait pas le fou. On reste sur du vert mec.
Allez, il a pas de vert Micka Voilà !
Ouais mais j'ai joué direct tu vois.
C'est pas grave, c'est pas grave. Il est faible, il est faible.
Hin hin !
T'as un +2 Cyril Alors ça tu vas bien  te faire fou*re !
*rires*
Bats les coui*les !  *rires*  Mais c'est le jeu, j'avais pas d'autre vert.
Pu*ain, fils de chi*n...
Ahhh !
Vas-y vas-y vas-y, envoie !
Ouais, j'ai pas j'ai pas j'ai pas...
Euh moi j'ai qu'un seul jaune.
Ahhh nan Cyril !
*rire*
Nonnnnn !
Mickalow: Non mais non !
Cyril: Merci Yann !
Allez, allez allez.
Mickalow: C'était une mauvaise idée !
Cyril: Ohhhhhhhh !
Mickalow: Olalaaaaa...
Cyril: C'est bon ça Lucas, bravo !
*rire*
Cyril: Très beau jeu.
Ohhhhhhh !!!
*rire*
Mickalow: Mais c'est pas Lucas qui va prendre du coup le... ! *rire*
Cyril: Donc si vous voulez bien je vais changer un peu le sens pour ... euh pour me venger un petit peu
Cyril : Mais nan !
Lucas : 'Tain !
Yann : Oh c'est pas la bonne... Oh t'aurais pu l'intercepter !
Cyril : L'erreur de Lucas !
Oh l'erreur ! Oh naaan
J'voulais qu'il gagne, il est nul à tout les jeux on peut lui laisser ça quoi
147 point et je vous emmerde
ok les gars 2 v 2 , j'espere je vais pas être avec Yann
et bein voila ... a non je suis avec cyril !
on est bien avec moi t'as vu Cyril ?
je pourrai te mener à la victoire
[rire malaisant] (joli haussement de sourcils de Squeezie btw) parce que là
allez
j'me sens pas à l'aise
Allez
*rire sadique*
p*tain
Mais merde
Pourquoi je me suis auto-volé
*Rires* Micka:mais qu'est-ce-qui est alala
Mais je sais pas, y'a un tuc qui apparait moi je clique p*****.
J'ai cliquer bande de sa****
P*****n j'ai niqué mes deux couleurs
Cyril je pourrais plus te mener a la victoire    Cyril: on est foutu, on est baisé* en vrai on a rien
Aller Cyril tu pioche de la bonne carte Cyril: Attention Micka: Il CONTESTE
YAOUUUUUH
Merci c'est bon ca Squeezie: Oh t'as bien pioché de la merde !
M: Yannou est-ce que ça serait pas la victoire ?
[S]: hé faut pas. Cyril je compte sur toi! [C]: aaah j'ai la pression!
NON! tu me tueras pas!
squeezie : OUI, oui bien joué, bien joué, bien joué
Là c'est bon ça
SQUEEZIE: ok, on change la couleur
*cris de joie*
Pu**** les meilleurs moves de monsieur Hauchard
Ca a duré 2 minutes
Ah ce move ! Ce move de Squeezie !
Squeezie: OK, c'est parti avec qui est-ce que je vais être
A pu**** je joue avec Micka. Micka on gagne c'est sûr.
Yann: C'est bon ça cyril
Cyril: Ouais...
Yann : nan mais pourquoi tu mets pas de
Cyril: mais non pas maintenant Yann voyons
squeezie: (rires) Les vieilles strats Il a un +4, il a un +4 c'te ba****
Micka : Lucas t'est prêt ou pas       squeezie : ouais...
Micka: Tu mets ta carte
squeezie: Ouais t'inquiètes vas-y vas-y OP LA
cyril: ok , ok on va faire pareil... euh non on peut pas on le fera plus tard
*rire*
Yann: on ne peut pas non
Cyril : exellent on apprécie
Micka : ca c'est pas gentil Yann par contre.
Cyril : tu sais quoi Yann j'ai meme envie de te suivre un peu
yann: attends attends attends !
squeezie : ok ok pas de soucis ça me va
*désespoir*
*rire*
Yann: c'est ça je voulais pas que tu le mettes, je voulais pas que tu le mettes
Jsuis désolé Yann j'ai pas réfléchi, j'ai eu peur.
Cyril : Lucas ENCHAINE. c'est la sentence
cyril : tout pour Micka... Non , il en a pas?
*rires*
Oh puta*n
Micka : et oui la technique parc'que ça a parlé et du coup
* Joie immense *
Micka: Et c'est Yannou qui prend le +12
Squeezie : allez Micka on va gagner, Micka on va gagner
Okay super bien joué
OH NON...OH OUI
Squeezie : c'est pour Yann
INCROYABLE
*rires* NOOOOOOOOOON
Yann : regarde la couleur, regarde la couleur, regarde la couleur JAUNE
Yann : NOOOOOON le jaune
Yann : fallait mettre le jaune
Mec t'as trop de cartes, j'ai mis 1h à les regarder je pouvais pas j'te jure mec
*rire* j'ai regardé j'ai dit "ouh là il y a trop de cartes"
c'est un fou, c'est risqué ça!
hann
Pu*** oh nann
Oh nannn
*rires* Oh puta*n
C'est pas grave Micka c'était calculé, c'était calculé Micka
Ok j'ai trois cartes Micka
Micka franchement on est bien, franchement on est bien
On va y arriver
Les mecs on est grave bien, on est grave bien
Vas-y, vas-y tu mets ton interdit, tu mets ton interdit
Ah si c'est bon, c'est bon, c'est bon. Ok
On est bien, on est bien, on est bien, on est bien
UNO !
Je mets ça...
Qu'est-ce que le bluff va marcher Micka
Cyril : Il a du rouge, il a du rouge
Oui j'ai du rouge, j'ai du rouge
Attention, attention, attention, attention...
Yann : J'ai pas d'autre choix, j'ai pas d'autre choix Cyril: Nan Yann pioche
*rires*
Yann : J'pensais qu'il bluffait, jpensais qu'il bluffait
Eh, j'ai fait un bluff d'un bluff mon gars. Qu'est-ce tu vas faire?
Il a bluffé le bluff
J'ai bluffé le bluff
D'ailleurs, ça me fait penser, j'vais mettre mes lunettes des joueurs de pocker.
S :Voilà   Micka : De même
Oh, attention on est ensemble, c'est beau ce qui se passe
Eh bien non je suis avec l'ancêtre, allez
Yann : Mais va te faire en**ler
*rires*
Les gars on fait un truc, l'équipe qui gagne celle là a tout gagné
Ba t'façon moi j'ai rien à perdre j'ai tout perdu
*rires de f*p*
Ouai grave
On va gagner Yann je le crois, allez Yann
On est bien Jackson, Oh le beau jeu
Qu'est-ce qu'il va faire Yannou ?
Oui, on va gagner Yann.
Oui.... Oui...
Mais nan pourquoi tu fais ça Yann
Yannou... Parce que jveux que tu prennes des cartes
Mais pourquoi, pourquoi tu veux que je prenne des cartes
Yann... Celui qui gagnes celle là va tout gagner
Cyril il a plus que deux cartes!
Oh, putain, c'est très dur Yann ce qu'il nous arrive
Oui c'est bon, il a pas de bleu, il a pas de bleu
He don't have blue.
Oui c'est bien
Oooh
N'oublies pas d'appuyer sur UNO c'est bien
Allez la bonne couleur
Mets du bleu *rires*
Je mets du vert.
Cyril : Yann tu veux gagner ouais ? Et bien non en fait
Ooooh, nooooon!
On est morts Yann, on est morts Yann
Yann : Ca me semble euh Oh il va intercepter il va intercepter !
Micka : Est ce que c'est un move à prendre ?
Attends prends ton temps prends ton temps
Micka : Nan nan fais moi confiance
J'ai mis du vert.
Mets ta carte p**ain de bordel de m***
*rires*
On a perdu la dernière game...
On a gagné ouiiii
Eh bien, non non non quittez, quittez!
Quittez c'est l'addiction, on va jamais s'en sortir
Eh ben les amis c'était une petite partie de UNO
J’espère qu'elle vous a plu
Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas a lâcher un pouce bleu.
Tout en disant UNO bien évidemment
*rires*
Contre pouce bleu !
Zut! Il vous a eu.
Allez à plus dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé.
Merci à Cyril, Micka, Yann, passez voir leur chaînes YouTube
C'est des gars en or
A très bientôt, portez vous bien, CIAO TOUT LE MONDE
*cri* J'ai fait une outro à la Fort Boyard
Toujours plus fort, toujours plus vite
C'est quoi, c'est ça non?
Toujours plus loin